[Musique]
mon truc c'est à chaque fois utilisé une
toutes nos passions une par une pour se
propulser de l'avant pour aller vers le
futur vers ce que nous sommes
je ne crois absolument pas en équilibre
absolument une chose c'est la passion
tous les gens qu'on a vu ce soit
incroyable de passion il ya eu un
échange parce qu'ils étaient passionnés
parce que vous êtes passionné une
inspiration s'est passé et je crois que
tout commence par les passions premières
scènes les plus importantes donc allez-y
le plus tôt possible donnez-vous à fond
dans quelque chose
est-ce que léonard de vinci aurait pu
faire de telles oeuvres d'art s'il
n'était pas un féru d'esthétisme sous
toutes ses formes est ce que steve
mcqueen aurait pu devenir ce qu acteur
génial s'il n'était pas d'abord et avant
tout un rebelle quelqu'un qui défier
l'autorité dc 10 12 ans aucune de ces
deux personnes n'a décidé un jour tiens
je vais essayer l' équilibre
non ils ont tous décidé dès le départ
dès lors 10 15 20 25 ans la passion
je suis venu il ya quelques années dans
le cadre d'un événement à lille qui
s'appelle à pirate king day c'est un
concept que j'avais cocquerez avec une
start-up local où on avait décidé de
mettre deux groupes de gens ensemble de
groupes de gens passionnés d'un côté
décodeurs les programmeurs et de l'autre
des artistes j'avais emmené mes copains
designer sculpteur comique de paris est
ensemble on avait pu créer une troisième
passion une passion pour la technologie
du bonheur il avait créé des petites
zappe
c'était à caton qui pouvait faire du
bien aux gens une des raisons pour
laquelle j'avais créé cet événement
c'est aussi parce que je crois fondation
fondamentalement dans les déclics de vie
donc ses grands moments
vous dites je sais pourquoi je suis là
je sais quel est l'impact que je vais
créer dans le monde
je sais qu'elle est ma trajectoire de
vie ou peut-être en tout cas en tout cas
j'ai un petit début alors moi ces gens
nés deux fils giorgio un peu un coin
paumé des états unis auquel je me suis
trouvé à 16 ans j'avais pas la bourse je
suis parti seul pour vivre à new york ou
miami donc je me suis retrouvé là bas ça
pas été tous les jours facile en 1990 un
jeune frenchie mais j'ai appris une
chose c'est le côté américain on peut
tous les jours se réinventer tous les
jours on peut devenir la personne qu'on
vote
il suffit juste de shop à l'américaine
j'ai tellement aimé cette expérience
d'immersion totale que j'ai recommencé
cette même expérience au japon trois ans
plus tard dans une famille japonaise
donc non que je ne connaissais pas une
culture que je connaissais pas et là ma
passion pour le japon m'a fait apprendre
de nouvelles choses sur la vie c'est la
passion pour la philosophie orientale
sur autant des états unis c'est sur
l'action immédiate court terme
autant le japon je vous conseille tous
d'y aller c'est cette réflexion
permanence sur notre action quelle est
la raison derrière l'action qu'on fait
et finalement avec ses deux postulats de
base à 20 ans lors de mon service
militaire je sais je date un petit peu
je décide de ma philosophie de jeu là je
l'écris sur mon sabre d'officiers être
sur un fil c'est vivre le reste n'est
qu'attente donc une sorte de pseudo
équilibre et finalement ses 20 ans de
carrière d'andy carrière différents dans
20 pays pendant 20 ans de 20 40 ans
n'ont pas besoin de parler de chacune sa
carrière peu importe finalement
ce qui importe c'est quand vous parlez
quelqu'un quand vous inspirait quand
vous animez quelque chose c'est de
qu'est ce que vous avez appris qu'il
peut utiliser autres quelques appris qui
peut les haines qui peuvent les anime et
qui peuvent surtout les aider à aller de
l'avant
alors il ya cinq ans j'ai tellement
passionné du développement personnel que
j'ai décidé d'en faire mon métier et je
suis devenu coach là c'est lors d'un
événement à new york
je voulais pas en parler mais ce mec là
c'est grâce à nada c'est tout simplement
ce genre d'histoire que j'adore un
ancien broker qui gagner des millions de
dollars et qui dit un jour je vais
devenir moi non il laisse tout tomber et
ce genre de ce genre d'histoires ça me
passionne et c'est ce que je cherche en
permanence du ferry d'histoire férus de
personnes mais ce que j'ai vu avec les
mille personnes en gros avec lesquels je
travaillais depuis cinq ans surtout dans
le monde de l'entreprise un petit peu
dans le monde individuel c'est une chose
c'est que chaque fois que je parle de
passion de bonheur de quête de sens les
gens y piges je m'entends parler il pige
avec le côté gauche du cerveau pas avec
le côté droit alors que c'est que le
cerveau droit lorsque vous prenez une
décision importante dans votre vie
surtout quand on parle de bonheur de
quête de sens de passion c'est le
cerveau droit qui parle selectrip on
sait pour utiliser la notre speaker qui
a parlé du deuxième cerveau c'est celui
ci très beau speech 20 par ailleurs donc
chaque fois que vous pouvez il faut se
demander cette petite voix intérieure
qu'est ce qu'elle me dis qu'est ce que
je dois faire maintenant il ya une chose
pour moi qui compte c'est la chose la
plus importante c'est le risque
on ne peut pas devenir passionnés vivent
de nos passions sans prendre de gros
risques
et quand je parle de risque jeunes
entendent bien c'est à dire pas prendre
un risque à 90 % 95 % en un an ça ne
marchera pas les choses sont les seules
choses qui vont marcher si vous prenez
des risques à 100% passionnément
obstinément intensément et là les choses
peuvent parfois marcher et parfois pas
et c'est pas grave puisque on va en
tirer quelque chose in fine est il ya
quelque chose toujours que vous allez
pouvoir ressortir de votre de cette
période de vie dans lesquelles vous êtes
mis sur votre passion alors là je
voudrais vous parler de d'un échec que
j'ai connu dans une de mes passions en
2004 comme dix mille personnes chaque
semaine
j'ai tenté l aventure hollywoodienne je
me suis dit je veux devenir acteur à
hollywood j'ai un peu tout fait pourquoi
pas j'étais pas le seul on arrive là bas
on se dit on arrive très fort et puis on
se retrouve avec plein de personnes du
monde entier qu'on aime rêve alors les
six premiers mois génial avec trente ans
un tout petit peu d'économies pour vivre
lui moi tout ce pas
bien j'achète une ancienne bagnole de
flics pour 1000 $ je m'amuse je vais
l'enregistrer à bel-air je fais de la
boxe pour la première fois du yoga la
vie est belle au bout de huit mois il ya
plus de il ya plus d'économies neuf mois
je commence petite déprime
et puis là je me dis il faut que quelque
chose se passe et je fais c'est physique
comme le mec de parcours qu'on a vu je
suis absolument confiant dans le fait
que le mental et le physique sont liés
et je me dis il faut que je me mette en
mouvement je marche dans les rues de los
angeles jusqu'à ce que quelque chose me
viennent il faut que je change mon fusil
d'épaulé
je suis pas venu acte je suis pas venu à
los angeles pour juste être serveur
c'est ce qui était en train de se passer
et là je tombe nez à nez sur sunset
boulevard
avec ça ça c'est le comedy store pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas c'est le
temple de la comédie aux etats unis
c'est là où andy kaufman eddie murphy
tous les grands comiques américains se
sont essayés alors moi personne ne me
connaît que j'aurais jamais et c'est
oser essayer la comédie en france jamais
je n'ai pas si drôle pour ça j'ai une
gueule un peu classique puis je vais
m'essayer de thiant et puis je sais pas
si c'est le miracle du débutant en quoi
ça marche la sauce prend il ya un
échange
il ya un échange avec les américains ce
qui fait que je me retrouve sur les
sites comme américain sur l'été
l'américaine est donc ça c'est une
grosse émission de comédie aux états
unis qui s'appelle la ce comics standing
je me dis j'aime tellement ce métier
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait que je fasse
pas ce qu'il y'a pas d'assedic du
spectacle aux états unis donc dès que ça
marche plus on est à la rue ça je peux
vous en j'ai rencontré peut-être une
dizaine de français qui dormaient dans
leurs voitures qui sont partis comme ça
à l'inconnu donc qu'est ce que je
pourrais faire pour que cette aventure
ne serait que jamais toute ma vie je
devienne je reste scénariste comique
acteur est là en fait j'étudie le marché
et je me rends compte qu'il ya à peu
près en appelant sags qui est le
syndicat des acteurs j'étais syndiqués
on ex en mille syndiqués sur 2 millions
d'acteurs si vous avez deux millions
d'acteurs à los angeles
il y en a mille seulement qu'ils peuvent
vivre de ce métier toute une vie quand
je dis
c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont pas besoin de
faire d'autres métiers 30 pendant 30 ans
40 ans est en gros chacun y est parvenu
par l'un de ses moyens où il a dégoté un
super cheap show il rentrait dans un
grand film américain où il avait son
propre film et je me suis dit
entrepreneur dans l'âme je vais monter
mon propre film ça doit pas être trop de
compliqué finalement j'ai monté pas mal
de projets je le faire et puis là à
nouveau miracle du débutant je ne sais
pas
la sauce prend en quelques mois je
récolte un peu de fond pas des millions
$ mais juste assez pour faire un film
pendant deux ans c'était une belle
aventure
taj mahal au japon là c'est avec le
docteur n'a camacho qui est une sommité
au japon personnage complètement dingos
c'était un film un docu comédie donc un
peu à la borat un peu plus gentil un peu
un peu différent je passe deux ans
complètement dingue de 2008 à 2010 et
puis retour sur terre des pressions à la
sa première fois de ma vie j'étais
quelqu'un de très positif optimiste
les français me dise naïf c'est une
qualité aux états unis pas en france
mais une qualité là bas hélas aucun
distributeur va vendre mon film j'avais
quand même embarqué ma femme dans
l'aventuré il avait quitté son emploi on
se retrouve à sec
moralement physiquement financièrement
ça a été très très dur mais maintenant
quand j'en parle ça a été une période
très difficile de ma vie pendant six
mois j'étais cloué au lit alors ça pas
été un échec total on a eu des world et
on est le plein de prix dans des
festivals mais vous savez ce n'est pas
ça qui compte 1 je connais plein de
réalisateurs qui ont plaintes qui sont
primés dans plein plein de festivals qui
arrivent pas payer leur loyer
donc c'est un succès d'estimé
pourquoi je vous ai parlé tout ça
passionnant ce qui m'est arrivé
aujourd'hui j'ai aucun regret ça a été
incroyable
mais aujourd'hui plusieurs années plus
tard j'ai compris j'ai pu en retirer les
leçons
donc ce que je voudrais que vous fasse
et que vaciller c'est que allez dans
votre for intérieur regarder ses
passions dans lesquels vous êtes mis à
fond et puis regardez ce que vous avez
pu en sortir une par une des choses qui
vont continuer à renouveler votre
passion et puis surtout animer votre
passion pour le futur et puis peut-être
impacté des gens c'est ce que je vois ce
que je fais dans mon métier depuis cinq
ans alors moi j'ai pu en tirer cinq
principes à nouveau c'est peut-être pas
des principes qui vont tous vous parlez
moi il me parle il parle à une certaine
partie de la population mais en tout cas
c'est ça c'est trouver ces leçons dans
les échecs dans lesquels on a vécu et de
choisir toujours et encore la passion
n'est pas l' équilibre
premier principe saisir les opportunités
j'ai eu une fenêtre de tir
je les prie aucun regret c'était génial
j'ai fait j'ai fait quelque chose dont
je rêvais
deuxième principe alors cette citation
elle me parle moi même je sais pas si
elle vous parle mais qu'est ce qu'elle
est belle c'est joseph kembo mon auteur
favori
la vie est un mystère qu'il faut vivre
et non un problème à résoudre
il ya rien de logique il faut arrêter de
planifier et si je fais ça ça va me
donner droit à ça et puis ça vivait tout
comme un mystère et moi en fait ça a été
ma faute c'est à dire que maintenant où
j'ai terminé mon film au lieu de
dissocier le fait que j'étais
réalisateur puis à mon côté producteurs
qui a pas marché je suis arrivé à vendre
de films mais mon côté réalisateur
finalement ça l'a fait
seba et les aux quatre coins du monde on
avait un film qui a fait rire les gens
sauf que voilà et en fait il faut
absolument dissocier ce que vous faites
au niveau d'expérience au niveau de vos
passions et puis le résultat poser vos
passions parce que un jour ça va payer
c'est sûr d'une manière ou d'une autre
et sûrement souvent presque presque tout
le temps dans un autre métier que dans
lequel vous avez commencé
troisième principe quand il ya une
impasse tout essayé entre 2010 et 2013
pour me refaire quand je dis me refaire
me refaire moralement physiquement
surtout tous les côtés
j'ai pris tous les mythes y est j'ai si
je me suis retrouvé dans un incubateur
de start up en afrique du sud
j'ai monté les soirées french tuesdays
pour ceux qui connaissent à tokyo qui
sont les plus grosses soirées française
dans des night clubs un truc
complètement dingue se retrouver en
tanzanie dans les quartiers chauds de
los angeles ait profs pour des petits
jeunes toutes sortes de métiers
1 parce que j'en avais besoin pour
bouffer et puis d'autres parce que ça
m'excite ce que j'essaye s'est trouvé
sept nouvelles vibrations cette nouvelle
où je pouvais me réaliser tous ces
métiers je n'allais pas me réalisés
incubateur de start up à faire du
volontariat s'était pas complètement
mois mais chaque fois que je prenais un
petit truc qui pouvait m'aider sur le
sur le futur et puis finalement fin 2013
comme quoi la vie c'est au fin fond de
tribus dans les quadeurs que je vois le
chaman parler j'étais là pendant trois
semaines je vivais comme et là il se
passe un truc magique
il ya un il y avait une vérité c'est
qu'ils ont tous enlever leur masse qui
était vrai il était pure et je me dis si
seulement je pouvais ramener ce que je
suis en train de vivre là aux états unis
en france dans les autres pays du monde
et c'est ce que j'ai fait depuis depuis
finalement bas 90 donc votre plus grand
échec peut-être votre plus grand moteur
donc finalement sans s'être défaite
échec je ne sais pas comment vous pouvez
l'appeler
jamais j'aurais pris la résilience la
vraie résilience pas celle qu'on lit
dans les bouquins dans celle qu'on vit
dans les tripes
jamais j'aurais pris autant le
storytelling finalement je me suis un
peu planté avec mon film et depuis je me
suis je vais devenir de meilleurs
storyteller j'ai pu aider quelques 200
personnes à exprimer leurs récits de vie
dans les deux dernières années et puis
bien sûr la profondeur je crois que je
restais un petit peu en surface allez je
dois l'avouer j'étais un petit peu en
surface avant de avant de
avant de vivre cette aventure du film et
finalement ça c'était dans un événement
n'est pas lié maintenant je vis des
ventes d aventure humaine mais
magnifique quelques jours j'étais au
maroc on sera au brésil bientôt les
trucs impactant chaque fois et ça c'est
dû à toutes les passions que j'ai pu
vivre et finalement la dernière le
dernier principe c'est la gratitude
alors je sais que les mots c'est des
mots qui peut-être que vous avez lu qui
vous parle plus trop faut le vivre là
aujourd'hui chaque jour je suis
conscient des bienfaits que je reçois de
la bonté des gens chaque jour avant de
me coucher je me dis qu'est ce que j'ai
appris aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui m'a surpris qui je peux
remercier et le lendemain matin je
remercie quelqu'un et je mate je
n'attends plus rien du tout maintenant
maintenant je fais je fais je fais mon
travail je donne je donne je donne et
parfois je reçois jamais des personnes
que je pense que je vais recevoir ou
déjà mais des événements que je pense
que je vais recevoir mais d'une manière
j'ai joué le kama le karma marche une
certaine manière
encore une fois pourquoi je vous ai
raconté tout ça je ne crois pas on
rééquilibre je crois incertaine et clip
de la passion est ce que ces gens sont
en équilibre ou sans déséquilibre je
suis sûr que si on demande à vous il ya
50% qui vont dire les choses l'autre ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'ils vivent leur
passion
ces gens pour moi je vais finir
là-dessus
la vie n'est pas un 100 m avec un truc
au bout de victoire et puis tous les
obstacles qu'on doit les les avoirs l'on
doit faire de parcours comme comme cette
équipe avant et puis si on gagne enfin
on est victorieux absolument pas c'est
tous et en fait j'ai pris une salle de
gym parce qu'une salle de gym on le fait
à son pas son désir on le fait quand on
veut quand on peut on travaille son
petit muscle puis on peut se reposer
personne nous dit quoi faire finalement
vous êtes votre propre coach vous êtes
vous êtes celui là personne qui peut
décider de votre propre réalisation
je voulais terminer là dessus pour moi
c'est un moment important ici que je vis
il ya 20 ans j'avais fait une émission
de télé en france sur le bonheur la
première en europe
une minute par jour j'ai parlé des mêmes
choses que je parle aujourd'hui sur le
bonheur la passion la quête de sens et
on m'a dit arnaud faut que tu te barres
parce que la france se sera jamais un
pays pour toi il faut que tu vivre aux
états unis au japon en afrique et c'est
ce que j'ai fait pendant 20 ans et
depuis deux ans je commence à revenir
parce qu'il ya une nouvelle énergie il
ya quelque chose qui se passe vous nous
l'avez prouvé ce soir tous les speakers
nous l'ont prouvé ce soir ensemble je
peux je pense qu'on peut oser oser
encore plus oser vivre avec passion
merci beaucoup l'île
[Applaudissements]